foreign
Tiffany is with us in Arizona hi Tiffany
welcome to the Ramsey Show
thank you for taking my call sure what's
up
um so back in
2014 my husband and I bought a rental
house with my parents
and then in 2015 we remodeled it my
husband and I paid all the expenses and
my father did the work
and then in 2016 my parents got divorced
and it was a very spiteful divorce
against each other
and my dad came to me and was like if
you give me five thousand cash under the
table
will be out of the rental property and I
was like I'm not going to do that
because you guys are both my parents I'm
knocking in the middle of it
so then he went down to the county clerk
and put a twenty thousand dollar lien on
the property
so we could not sell it because there
was not enough equity to cover the lien
and we've tried paying him three times
he won't take the money because he has
to split with my mom
so we're just kind of stuck we don't
really know what to do next
wow
confessions of someone who should not
have bought real estate in a partnership
huh
we're financially able to no that wasn't
what I said confessions of someone that
should not about
real estate in a partnership which is
anyone by the way because the only ship
that Won't Sail is a partnership
including one with spiteful divorced
parents and your dad is completely
butthole oh my God
I'm so sorry for you
what a jerk
okay so what's the property worth
it's worth 63 and we owe 17.
oh it's a big old property too
everybody's gonna get rich on this crap
what's your household income
um probably right now I'd say about 150.
what's your net worth
about 500 000.
okay there's a couple of ways to go at
this
structurally
relationally and spiritually
okay
um
Justice would be served but not common
sense
by way number one
and it's not my suggestion but this will
work
okay
way number one is you hire an attorney
and you sue the partnership in court for
the disillusionment of the partnership
assets and you for it and the judge will
force the sale of the house and he will
deal with the illicit twenty thousand
dollar lien in the process
okay
and the in other words the judge would
remove the twenty thousand dollar lien
because you could present evidence that
in State Court this is a state course
not a federal court move you'd have to
talk to an attorney it's going to cost
you ten or fifteen thousand dollars to
do this
okay and your butthole dad is out of the
picture forever because once you Sue
this jerk he's never going to speak to
you again okay
and he's a jerk yeah okay but that might
that may not be a big loss but it is
your dad it still breaks your heart
dads should not do this to their
daughters by the way that's just it's
not normal that's strange
so um
but that technically is how you would
get out of a bad partnership is you sue
for the disillusionment of the
partnership assets the judge says you
have to sell it they sell it slow sale
with a real estate agent or at an
auction and he can also rule on the
illicit illegal lien which is what
you're telling me this is okay yeah in
the process uh now if you want to go
that route you can go that route that
would be Justice that'd be the the
correct thing would happen then is he
would not get the twenty thousand
dollars that he's not due the property
would be sold and the appropriate people
would get the money all you although you
would be out attorney's fees and you
could sue for those and throw them in
there I assume there's no partnership
agreement
no of course another problem
when you give your dad that money half
of that's mine so I feel like I'm in the
Middle where I can't make no it's not
it's like I'm not giving your dad
anything that's not the point yeah okay
yeah we're not you're not going that
route
okay your dad does not do any money
is he
I mean I no no his deal was he did the
work and you furnished the repairs that
was the deal
he's not due any money morally
did I miss something
we didn't pay him for the work I know he
for it you didn't get paid back for
putting up the stuff either did you no
okay that was the deal
quick covering for this jerk
am I missing something
no I mean he helped with the down
payment too that was 5 000 but even when
we try to just give him the 5 000 cash
he wouldn't take it we tried giving him
five thousand ten thousand yeah here's
the other way here's the other way
here's the other way out this is this is
90 headache and 10 percent
fruit
you know what I would do if I were you I
assume you're on the mortgage right
yeah I would I would pay off the
mortgage today
and sign a quit claim deed to these two
fools and let them go work it out and
walk away
just give it to them screw them
let them go burn them burn it down it's
sixty three thousand dollars who gives a
crap you've got a half a million you
make 120. this is not life-changing
money to you what is life-changing is
your parents are being twerps
yeah just walk away just toss them the
keys over your shoulder
and say you two figure this out good
luck you children
and just forget it I was waiting for a
closure it was worth over 200 000 and
they owed 90 and they sent it back to
the bank instead of selling it agreed to
sell it so money isn't really the issue
I'm not talking about them I'm talking
about you yeah this is not about money
this is about fools
cut yourself loose from Fools
else right now are you guys renting it
is it sitting vacant yeah we're
we're low like the value is not high of
the property the rental
um it's worth 1 000 a month so let me
tell you by the time you split all this
crap up if you spend fifteen thousand
dollars in attorney's fees instead of
seventeen thousand paying off the
mortgage and you go through all this
crap you're going to end up with ten
thousand bucks in your pocket aren't you
well after everything's said and done
after all the crap goes on if you sue
them and do it and you fight through
this for two and a half years in the
legal system and you get this house sold
your net in your pocket is going to be
between ten and twenty thousand dollars
isn't it
yeah yeah it is the numbers you just
gave me
happened in Illinois they passed a new
law that's effective one 123 that where
if a lien expires which this one expired
in 2018 that you don't have to go
through the leaner to get the person who
put the lien on to get it removed
um because I apparently there were a lot
of contracts it's not the lien that's
the problem you're on a mortgage and a
deed with two fools
oh they're not their names not on the
property at all it's just our name oh
this is new information yeah it's all in
our name because they were in I know
this is super stupid I did this but um
they were in chapter 13. oh you guys are
under the is it under the table family
we do illegal stuff for a living here
okay yeah I you know I might well I
thought they were on the loan with you
and on the on the house okay in this
case I would just sue him
just show him and get the lean removed
that's simple just suit suit just
following with a court follow with the
court and get the lean removed that
simple and then don't give them anything
screw them that's the way I mean just
just when you if you want to give them
something someday that's fine but not
now yes we talked about that last call
all the way through the commercial break
and you did two that's why you listen to
the Ramsey Show because it's a little
Cherry springer-ish around here
sometimes so um oh my gosh
um so here's the thing finally in the
last 30 seconds got the information
before we move on to the next part that
the ownership of the property was in the
girl's name her and her husband own it
so the only hold mom or dad have on that
property is a moral hold where they did
a handshake
partnership
but there is no legal hold on that
property at all and dad has placed a
lien on the property that can be removed
with a small attorney's fee of three to
five thousand dollars so if you have a
contractor that you pay and they're
pissed and they say you owe me an extra
five grand but no that wasn't our deal
and they placed a lien on your property
you can sue that contractor and have
that removed have that lien removed for
you know a couple thousand bucks in
state court it's not a big deal it's a
quick hearing may even be you know maybe
just local small claims court even
possibly depending on how your area is
so see an attorney honey and just sue
the contractor that placed lien on your
property the the contractor
being your butthole dad will settle the
twenty thousand dollars for three
thousand bucks and walk away you give
them the three thousand dollars now you
own the property free and clear you have
no moral obligation to people who tried
to cheat you
in an Unwritten partnership agreement uh
to pay them anything you now just own
the property and they're just out to
plunge which is where they deserve to be
they were in Chapter 13 when you bought
the property anyway we used your name
your credit your money to buy the
property to start with the only thing
they did was come up with a really bad
idea and stick you in it
and so they get nothing which is exactly
what these two groups deserve parents
misbehaving on the Jerry Springer Show I
mean the Ramsey Show and so that's the
title of that call
uh one last thing Christina's asking me
about something else what about the
Biblical scripture says to honor your
father and mother you are supposed to
honor the office
of Father the office of mother but we do
not honor your dad if he sexually
molests you
we honor the office of father but we do
not honor a sexual predator we do not
honor mom if she's doing cocaine and
stealing your children's college fund
you honor the office of mother but that
mother has has severed her rights to be
honored as an individual
because of her misbehavior biblically
speaking and so you're not biblically
bound to honor people who are
misbehaving in any situation well I
think that's important to highlight
because I think a lot of Christians can
feel guilt around that and there are
other families nothing as guilty as an
Evangelical Christian we can do guilt
better than almost anybody maybe
Catholics beat us but I mean it's we're
right in there together buddy we got we
got guilt down to a science but yeah
it's not there's nothing to feel guilty
of here you're not you're the victim
you're not the perpetrator